>> Tammy: YESTERDAY, JOE BIDEN
STOOD BEFORE THE WORLD AND
PROCLAIMED THAT THE TALIBAN'S
TAKEOVER OF AFGHANISTAN CAME AS
A TOTAL SURPRISE.
THE ASSUMPTION WAS THAT MORE
THAN 300,000 AFGHAN NATIONAL
SECURITY FORCES THAT WE HAD
TRAINED OVER THE PAST TWO
DECADES AND EQUIPPED WOULD BE A
STRONG ADVERSARY IN THEIR CIVIL
WARS WITH THE TALIBAN.
THAT ASSUMPTION THAT THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO HOLD
ON FOR A PERIOD OF TIME BEYOND
MILITARY DRAWDOWN TURNED OUT NOT
TO BE ACCURATE.
>> YEAH, WOW, THAT WAS AN
OBVIOUS LIE.
HE SAID THE SAME THING TO
STEPHANOPOULOS ON ABC.
ACCORDING TO REUTERS NOW.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS THIS AND
IT'S TRUE.
IT'S NOT THE BABYLON BEE.
BIDEN KNEW THAT THE COLLAPSE WAS
INEVITABLE.
HE DIDN'T WANT ANYONE TOLLS KNOW
ABOUT IT IN LATE JULY DURING A
PHONE CALL WITH PRESIDENT ASHRAF
GHANI, BIDEN TOLD HIM TO PRETEND
LIKE THE TALIBAN WASN'T READY TO
RETAKE THE COUNTRY, SAYING,
QUOTE:  I NEED NOT TELL YOU THE
PERCEPTION AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN PARTS OF AFGHANISTAN, I
BELIEVE, IS THAT THINGS AREN'T
GOING WELL IN TERMS OF THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE TALIBAN.
AND THERE IS A NEED WHETHER IT'S
TRUE OR OR NOT THERE IS A NEED
TO PROJECT A DIFFERENT PICTURE.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT IS
RETIRED ARMY INFANTRY CAPTAIN
AND U.S. SENATE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE SEAN PARNELL.
SEAN, I THINK THAT THIS IS NOT
LIKE GUESSWORK OR RHETORIC OR
HYPERBOLE, THAT A CONFESSION, A
RECOGNITION THAT THE COUNTRY WAS
IN TROUBLE AND ASKING THE
PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN
EFFECTIVELY TO LIE ABOUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON, WHICH MEANS ALSO,
YOU WILL NOT BE PREPARED BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T PREPARE BECAUSE YOU'RE
TELLING PEOPLE SOMETHING THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNBELIEVABLE, BUT NOBODY SHOULD
BE SURPRISED.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN A POLITICIAN
IN WASHINGTON FOR 50 YEARS AND
LYING IS WHAT HE DOES.
HE SAID HE GRADUATED AT TOP OF
HIS LAW SCHOOL.
THAT WAS A LIE.
HE SAID HE HAD DEGREE THREE
DEGREES.  THAT WAS A LIE.
HE SAID HE OPPOSED THE IRAQ WAR
THAT WAS A LIE.
HE SAID HE WAS THE FIRST IN HIS
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE IN A
THOUSAND GENERATIONS.  THAT WAS
A LIE.
HE SAID HE WAS A COAL MINOR FROM
PENNSYLVANIA.  THAT WAS A LIE,
TOO.
THAT'S WHAT THIS MAN DOES.
FOR GOODNESS SAKE, HE SAID HE
WAS IN A KNIFE FIGHT WITH A GUY
NAMED CORN POP.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tammy: WHEN WE THINK BACK
LYING ABOUT YOURSELF, IT GIVES
PEOPLE A HINT ABOUT YOUR
CHARACTER AND YOUR NATURE.
BUT, NOW THE LIES HAVE GOTTEN 13
OF OUR SERVICE MEMBERS MURDERED.
THOUGHT LIES UNTOLD NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE IN AFGHANISTAN WILL BE
SLAUGHTERED.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BLOODBATH.
THAT IS I THINK, WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR SOME REASON
HAVE NOT MADE THE CONNECTION YET
WITH WHO THIS MAN IS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND HE DID THIS EXACT SAME THING
IN UKRAINE.
FIRED THE PROSECUTOR WHO IS
INVESTIGATING MY FAMILY'S
CORRUPT BUSINESS DEALINGS IN
YOUR COUNTRY OR YOU DON'T GET
THE BILLION DOLLARS.
RIGHT?
LIE ABOUT THE CONDITIONS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND, OTHERWISE, YOU
WON'T GET THE MILITARY
ASSISTANCE.
THEY DON'T CALL HIM QUID PRO-JOE
FOR NOTHING.
AND THE MOST HORRIBLE THING
ABOUT ALL OF THIS, TAMMY, THE
FACT THAT HE HAD TO LIE MEANS
THAT HE KNEW SIX WEEKS AGO THAT
THINGS WERE GOING TO GO BAD.
>> Tammy: THAT'S CORRECT.
>> YET, HE DIDN'T ADDRESS THIS
STRATEGY.
HE DIDN'T WARN AMERICANS IN THAT
COUNTRY TO LEAVE.
HE DIDN'T TELL OUR MILITARY.
>> Tammy: WE GOT RID OF BAGRAM.
ALL THE TERRORIST PRISONERS
BEING RELEASED IT'S ALMOST AS
THOUGH IT WAS BY DESIGN AND WE
HAVE GOT TO CONSIDER THE NATURE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE AND I
KNOW IT'S SHOCKING.
I THINK MOST OF AMERICANS ARE
STILL IN SHOCK.
BUT AS WE GET THESE DETAILS,
THAT'S WHAT TONIGHT IS ABOUT,
SEAN.
TONIGHT IS ABOUT THE OVERFLOW,
THE LAVA COMING OUT OF THE VALUL